along journée by the former pensions
minister baroness altman so rose is this
a good idea
well in its certainly absolutely right
that we have to control the costs of
state pensions and be fair to younger
generations so I understand exactly
where the government's coming from on
this and it is in line with John
Cridland review but I must admit that I
would prefer to see more recognition of
the individual differences that there
are in life expectancy across the
country and between different
socio-economic and occupational groups
so in other words you'd like to see
different occupations getting the state
pension at different times of their
lives then not necessarily but I think
we need to recognize that there are very
big differences in life expectancy
across the country and our current state
pension age policy is purely geared to
the average life expectancy and there
are lots of people who are if you like
below average and now of course that's a
function of the state pension system
that we've got but in the end if people
are paying let's say a quarter of their
salary in national insurance and they
end up getting little or no state
pension at all there's a problem of
fairness within generations
so perhaps allowing people to take their
state pension sooner either because
they've had a very long contribution
period international insurance let's say
someone who had a very heavy manual
labour job left school at 15 or 16
allowing them to get their state pension
from say 65 or 66 if they've contributed
for 50 or more years to national
insurance would still control the costs
because not many people would end up
with exactly 50 years worth of
contributions and we have to control the
costs but we need I think to have more
flexibility yeah this is gonna affect a
lot of people who are 46 45 47 I mean
does this give them long enough to get
their houses in order and to arrange
they can and for them to save more well
one of one of the big issues that we've
got of course is that people need to
know what the state pension age
might be and at the moment there are a
lot of people who haven't been well
informed about their state pension age
but ideally what you want I think to do
is get rid of the idea that the state
pension age is a retirement age actually
a lot more people are now going to be
able to work longer that's fantastic
news
people are living longer and generally
can be healthier as well and can work
because work isn't so physically
demanding and if we had a range of Ages
so that you don't expect there's one
magic age when you suddenly stop work
that would I think help the labor market
and it would give people a better
lifetime income right now unfortunately
the way our state pension system works
it's only geared to help those who are
healthy and wealthy enough to wait
before they get the state pension if you
wait longer you can get more state
pension but if you really really
desperately need it sooner you can't get
a penny yes now looking at the
practicalities of this the government
has said it's not going to legislate on
this but actually leave it until 2023
run the next strategic review the next
review of the state pensions age comes
in I mean isn't there a danger that the
government is kicking this problem down
the road for a future government to have
to deal with I think that's exactly what
what is part of part of the rationale
here we are going to have another review
of state pension age in the next
parliament anyway and to be honest our
state pension system our national
insurance system when it comes to
retirement support is deficient and
needs review in any case because right
now all there is for retirement really
on a national level is the state pension
there is nothing for Social Care that
people might need you know extra income
if they can't live independently in
advanced old-age if beverage was
designing our national insurance system
today he would obviously include some
provision national insurance type
provision for those who lived till much
later life so well while we're looking
at those issues and the government has
to has to address the social care crisis
and we have to help fund social care
across the across the country and for
future generations to look at it very
briefly what about this issue of inter
general generational um furnaces and
already a lot of resentment about the
cost of the triple lock I mean again
this is just feeds than the idea that
the baby boomers have consumed all the
wealth and subsequent generations are
going to have to pay for it well there
is no doubt that the state pension in
future is going to be lower for future
generations that's part of the new state
pension and I understand that people are
not comfortable to some degree with that
but actually the good news should be
that we've had such success in people
keeping people healthy longer and making
work physically easier that they can
take advantage of opportunities to work
longer and have a much higher lifetime
income that's the good news bit we just
need to make the rest of our framework
fit the good news that that there is out
there all right Roz Aultman baroness
oldmen appreciate you joining me thank
you